If you had purchased the computing power found
inside an iPhone 5S in 1992, it would have
cost you $3.56 million.
Lenin owned nine Rolls-Royces.
Humans spend 13% of their lives not focusing
on anything in particular.
Fishing lakes in remote areas of California
are stocked by throwing baby trout out of
planes flying over the water at 200 mph.
There is more water in the Earth's core than
in all of its oceans.
Prisoners waiting to be executed on Death
Row in America are given a physical beforehand,
to ensure they are fit enough to die.
Until 1916, cocaine and heroin could be bought
over the counter at Harrods.
Kevin Kadish, the co-writer of “All About
That Bass”, has only received $5,679 from
178 million plays of the song on streaming
services.
That's roughly $0.00003 per stream.
In 117 ad, Emperor Hadrian declared attempted
suicide by soldiers, a form of desertion and
made it a capital offence.
The ancient Greek philosopher Heraclitus attempted
to cure a serious illness by lying in the
sun covered in cow dung.
He died the following day.
Prison inmates in Chile have better mental
health than the average American.
The theoretical process of knocking a meteoroid
of course with a nuclear explosion is called
an 'X-ray slap'.
Four million years ago, rats in South America
were the size of hippos.
The Pentagon is successfully hacked 250,000
times a year, and unsuccessfully hacked 10
million times a day.
A whole orange will float on water, but it
sinks if you peel it.
Stephen Hawking was born exactly 300 years,
to the day, after Galileo died.